let's take it easy we can introduce
ourselves they won't care who we are so
I said who are you
so I'm bill Wagner if you read docs on
docs on Microsoft comm under C sharp
that's what I'm responsible for a lot of
the newer ones since I've only been with
the company about two and a half years
I've been writing and I try to explain
the company seeing things he comes up
with so who are you I'm master Gerson
and I'm a program manager on the on
the.net team and I'm the lead designer
for C sharp so I come up with the crazy
things and then he makes him sound like
you know they were planned and and
thought-out so it's a good partnership
and we couldn't we couldn't resist the
the opportunity to grab a Shakespearean
title here since so honestly what
happened again let's start a little slow
people still coming in so what happened
was these new features are about to come
out and see sharp and a lot of people
interested in them lots of Microsoft
people apparently said yes to come here
at the same time and so we all submitted
the same talks with the same titles and
the same abstracts and then when we
realized that we were about to do the
same things we're like Oh to talks about
nullable reference types why don't we
join up and then make it like a two-hour
tour de force about essentially about
nothing figured Seinfeld succeeded so
two hours about nothing sure yeah so so
this is much ado about nothing Act one
in which I'm the hero and a meaning that
I will do most of the talking and I got
the keys and then I'll try to be nice to
build because in the second act which is
after the break he will have the keys
and you will have the power and whatever
I do to him he will do to me 100 fold
which is you know all Shakespearean
English talk is tomorrow yes so we
should be nice to John as well John
skeet is here on the front row he also
submitted the same talks so so sorry
about that
so we will start out by sort of
exploring the general the the history
and and nature of the null references
and also the what we've tried to do
about it what we're trying to do about
it in c-sharp so that sort of language
design aspect of what we're calling
nullable reference types so the history
of nothing
the history of nothing yes we can make
this joke a lot of times it doesn't get
any funnier no it's it's essentially
vacuous so and then so that's sort of
like the language to signee stuff like
maybe the Computer Sciences stuff a
little bit and then there's like okay
how do I actually use this what does it
mean for me in source code and that may
be a little more C sharp specific
there's going to be more code in bills
section but also you know much more
practical and you know we're about C
sharp but I think that a lot of what
we're doing with this feature is
relevant to pretty much any
object-oriented language on the planet
so and maybe more so even if you're not
a c-sharp developer how many people in
here are sheesh up developers okay let's
just get that out of the way okay how
many are not alright okay
well there we go
so so I think people stopped filing in
now so let's let's dive into the
substance here so we all know that truth
is found in in Nursery Rhymes I'm
particular the British ones I love the
British ones because they are you know
they're all about gently introducing
unsuspecting kids to the the violence
and death that surrounds us in society
like the pretty gruesome
and so this is this is no exception here
and this particular one is about nulls
right they're all these ships that are
missing the null sheep as it were that
just leaves empty shapes left and you
know there's a goes little bow beef has
lost her sheep and doesn't know where to
find them leave them alone and they'll
explode throwing exceptions behind them
so that pretty much six expresses what
we all know and feel and have for the
last many centuries of object-oriented
programming so there's a villain in this
story you see this villainous evil grin
here this is Sir Tony Hoare he's one of
the grandfather's of computer science
he's still around
he joined Microsoft research in
Cambridge right around the time when I
was interning there two decades ago and
he's retired now but he still comes in
on Thursdays because he just um you know
can't help himself now he's helping Don
Syme introduce nulls to f-sharp I think
yes that's probably true so he so he
once famously claimed that that null
references were his billion dollar
mistake like he he gave a very quoted
talk where he essentially sort of
tongue-in-cheek took responsibility for
all the billions of dollars that have
been wasted on null reference exceptions
over the course of history because he
actually invented null references and
it's pretty amazing that something like
that was ever invented right but
actually they were like he was there
along with Nicklaus weird Liat trying to
come up with a proposed successor to al
Ghul
they're like you know there's been these
have been these advances in computer
science let's let's try to propose a new
version of this very popular imperative
language called Al Gore and they call it
so it's been referenced Algol W so they
came up with really great things like
reference types ok so you can point to
other things and that can all be typed
and expressed in a type system and at
the end of the day
Algol W was rejected by the algo
committee they had much more important
things on their mind and they went and
took Algol 68 in completely different
direction and it totally tanked right
instead Niklaus Tony's partner in crime
went and came up with this thing called
Pascal okay
taking these ideas from olw and turning
them into a different programming
language which of course became the you
know essentially the lingua franca of
high-level imperative programming for
decades after that so so even though
algal W never really became anything in
and of itself it had a massive impact on
history of programming language math and
the other thing that it influenced with
the reference types was the first object
going to programming language so here's
sort of a like it's a quick genealogy of
programming languages algal W here never
really was released nobody wrote code in
it ever except for Tony and and Nicholas
themselves but it has had this massive
influence including on similar 67 which
was the first object on a programming
language and and then of course all this
all of the languages that followed and
essentially not only did reference types
make it across to object on your
programming our central concept in
object-oriented programming when you
think about it but the null reference is
sort of came along this disease vector
as well and they in fact it all about
you're going to programming through
these arrows here so I mean when you
think about it objects really can't the
object program can't exist without this
notion of reference type so that
similarly introduced the notion of
inheritance and you have these different
classes that are abstracted over by that
by a shared base class or a superclass
and that can only really work if you're
sort of in directed through a reference
they have different shape different
sizes and shapes right there has to be
this indirection in order for that to
even work and the references themselves
become object identities so which is a
central concept in OP January
programming so al ghul table you really
opened up that whole thing and made
similar 67 click together with these
notions of inheritance and so on that
that they had it just because NDC is
rooted in Norway I want to put the two
Norwegian inventors of up you're going
to programming up here in a slide as
well very cool people so but from there
I'm really gonna that's sort of gentle
introduction to the topic but I'm really
just gonna flip into Visual Studio now
and do the rest of the talk in encode
codes good yeah right yeah so and I
don't think people I think people will
appreciate having live explosions
instead of ones and slides so so let's
go and make some live explosions so one
of the things so I want to start by
talking about you know sort of intuiting
what might have happened in so Tony's
head you know one of the things that you
can do with reference types is that it's
really good for expressing recursive
types right so let's say he's writing
he's implementing linked lists in Algol
W back in in 1965 and he's there he came
up with this recursive I'm writing it as
a class here in c-sharp but he came with
this recursive type that's sort of a
linked list okay and so he's like okay
what does the linked list have it has a
some content in the node and then it has
a link to the next one and a constructor
okay that's that's good so let's let's
create ourselves a any link here okay we
can and I just made one of strings here
to make it easy that you don't think
they had generic types back then so you
know we can say new link of hello and
then we need another link there okay so
I can create another link it's a new
link world and
then I need another link and I so at
some point you know this has got to stop
I can't keep creating new links and
passing to it so at some point I have to
pass it something other than a new link
okay and you've made like it's like 3
a.m. now and his tie and he's like
alright then okay let's let's put this
thing in here okay let's add that to the
language so that I can stop creating new
objects and and you know um and my and
my statement here and sonal is
introduced it's the thing that you use
when you have no more things and look at
ons it and it looks innocent right it's
kind of almost necessary you can it's
it's pretty well it's pretty well
motivated alright now the next morning
Niklaus comes in and and you know I
Tony's fast asleep he didn't even show
up until after after lunch that day but
Niklaus is like hey he put in recursive
types I'm not going to do the German
accent and she's like hey let me let me
write this out to screen you know static
void I'm just totally pretending this is
alcohol w I'm just doing it in c-sharp
okay static void French let's take a
link and that's print it out how hard
can that be
so let's see what does it have I can
write line the links content so there's
a value in there great I printed that
first one out and then we can recur it's
a recursive data structure we can just
recursively print out the rest link the
next done you know great wonderful and
we compile and we run and you're not
actually calling it I'm not calling you
that's a good observation okay
let's actually call it so they'll print
of that thing I just created okay now
[Music]
you know
I think we compile it before I called it
and boom we have an exception the
world's first not reference exception
has occurred so that's what I mean by
live explosions so we printed hell over
into the world and we ran over the edge
and we died and and of course this has
been with us ever since because we never
really dealt with this it was like okay
back then we had bigger fish to fry so
but we never really recovered from this
and we still so this is C sharp today
perfectly legal program runs over the
edge just like in algal W 54 years ago
and that's not entirely good you know I
love you so Tony's right he's kind of
tongue-in-cheek when he says you know
I'm sorry for ever having invented the
null reference because what else would
you do what else would you have done
right how else would you have solved the
oh I made it to the edge kind of problem
but you know what what he what he means
is you know we just introduced this
thing completely outside of the type
system and we're not even trying to deal
with it in a and we're not even trying
to introduce the kind of type safety
that we apply to everything else so so
the question of what else could we do
that has you know getting riddling us
ever since the the functional folks they
have it figured out okay so if you go to
look at functional programming languages
they actually the dealt with this pretty
neatly and what they said is so they
have a very reasonable line of thinking
about this which is saying okay there's
not we shouldn't be talking about just
the link type here there's links and
then there's not links there's two
different kinds of things there's I have
one and I don't have one and those are
two different kinds of values so there
are two different types and we can have
a union type between them that says this
particular field or parameter or
whatever is either that or the other
okay so they have this notion of Union
types and based on Union types we can
express as a special case things that
are either there or not
and
we don't have union types in c-sharp but
you can you can model eight pretty well
using inheritance right so so actually
starting with similar they'd had no
excuse they could have done this but you
know you can we can say this an option
of see I made a generic here you know an
option of T which you know has Drive
classes none or some which is either
there was nothing so there's this empty
empty class here for when there's
nothing and there's another subclass
when there's something and they're all
options of T's so I can abstract over
whether it's nothing or something I know
the the something has a value inside and
it can be constructed and it can be
deconstructed like in you know we do in
modern c-sharp so we could go and solve
the problem and sort of put the nulls in
the type system so let's do that quickly
here and it gets a little more tedious
but that's mostly because the language
isn't completely it's not completely
native to the language so instead of
having just a link next year and and and
relying on the ability of that to be
secretly null we're going to be explicit
and say this is actually an option of
link either is a link or there isn't if
I could hit the keys here so it's option
of link next okay
and now of course I need to adjust my my
constructor a little bit but that's
that's that's pretty much it for the
implementation and and but now we see a
warning show up to place first of all my
constructor changed I need to do some
more constructing here in order to get
those option types in but I also but
this this warning down here is that this
arrow down here is what I want to get to
in a minute but let's let's make it
happy by creating a instead of passing a
link to the constructor I have to create
a some link that has the link inside and
instead of C and keep my friends
straight here in it instead of passing a
link now I think the type needs to be
careful there careful oh oh yeah it's
just pure programming it's all good
that's great
and now that goes away
I can still pass a null here but I
really shouldn't I should be passing a
new none uplink and and and put the safe
null in there okay so I'm create so I
have a nun at the bottom and then I have
somes clapped around it so now we made a
types a version of the linked list and
what we have down here is it shows that
it's type safe we have the linked up
next here is no longer allowed because
well first of all it's not allowed
because I can't print an option of link
I can only print a link right the print
method isn't recursively calling itself
yet well how do I get to the next link
so I can print it I have to fish it out
of the of the option but I can only do
that if the option is a sum and not a
nun so I have to do it conditionally
okay so it's forcing me to say if linked
up next is a sum of link then
deconstructed and get the next link out
okay and now we can in the in this if
statement here that so I get a fresh
variable with a link but only if it was
there only if the thing was a sum and
then in the inside of the if statement I
have that next variable that actually
refers to a link in that I can
recursively print out and so now I have
the safe printing that I think we should
even try to compile and run and see that
it does the right thing now okay so it
forces me to check for null the type
system forces me to check in right I
like that so that's the kind of thing
that we want have the type system
helpers realize that we have a null
problem and now this particular way of
going about it it's it's fine you know
we can just have a language without
native nulls in it and we can just build
our own nulls with using discriminated
unions it does have some limitations
right one of the this is one way of
using nulls where you really want a null
you really want
in the finished data structure you want
there to be an end you want it to be and
there's no more here but sometimes
that's not what nulls are for sometimes
you're you sort of have as you're
building up your object graph you have
temporary nulls
right this is all in front this is all
from functional programming which you
know you construct values from other
values always and you're in principle
you're never mutating them right you're
just so you can never actually build a
cyclic data structure you can because
you always have to have the thing that
the next thing is constructed from so if
you have a you've want to build a cyclic
data structure well I can't create this
object before I created the one that it
points to all the way around like in the
whole cycle yes somebody has to be first
and and you know okay so if we have a
mutable programming language how do you
create a cyclic data structure well you
have to create one of the objects first
and then you can create all the other
ones that point to it but at some point
only you at some point did you create
the one that the first object is
pointing to and so in the meantime what
was it what was in there before it
pointed to the thing it should
eventually point to so even if you have
a finished data structure that has no
nulls in it there's this whole
initialization problem of well what was
it until you were able to assign it the
reference and sort of more in general
many of our most of our mutation
oriented programming languages they have
more dynamic ways of creating data like
in in c-sharp and Java you can create a
race great an array of string yes and I
don't want it like pay for all those
constructor calls right that would take
time yeah so it's fine to type so we
kind of need this idea of default values
create an array you even computed its
size at runtime you're creating array of
string well it's it'll just feel full of
nulls because null is the only sensible
default value of string even if strings
were not supposed to be now like what
else would you use as a default value
and the notion of default value of sort
of a zero value is deeply entrenched in
most normal languages and for a reason
right it's really hard to create a
programming language that's statically
safe and does not have a notion of the
all value of a given type so in practice
this runs out of steam in a in a more
mutation oriented more object-oriented
programming language this approach but
it has some really really good
properties that we want to and we want
to latch on to if we're trying to solve
this problem for an object on a
programming language the key property
that I think is the most important one
here is that it's explicit about intent
this link and there's option of link
okay and there are two different types
one can be null over here and the other
one can't okay so you explicit in the
type system about your intent and then
the second thing is that there's
enforcement of this intent I cannot
possibly well I would have to contort
myself badly in order to circumvent the
type system and get at something that
isn't there it's really hard for me to
accidentally get a null reference
exception here right essentially have to
cast and do unsafe things so so yeah the
way I've said that when we were
explaining these concepts is our type
system protects against Murphy not
Machiavelli yes yes so so if you really
want yes you can get into trouble but
you kind of have to ask for trouble more
and so the ideal here is you know
enhance the type system to allow
expressing whether null is intended or
not in a given place where you use a
type and as much as possible enhance the
type system to enforce that knowing that
we can't get all the way there because
of these initialization problems you
know because of default values and stuff
we can't get all the way there to making
it a hundred percent safe and there are
other reasons why we can't get all the
way to make it 100 percent safe one of
the reasons being that it's one thing to
create a new programming language today
and deal with nulls in it from scratch
but we're actually creating an old
programming language today right we have
C sharp already lying around had it for
20 years
and now we want to go and fix the type
system and so that limits us so much
more in terms of how we can approach
this we're gonna try it's good and this
is one of the things I'm really
interested in especially when we get
later when I want to further my grades
come some code I have to use this
and see you know how much benefit do I
get in and how much does it hurt yeah
I'm worried about the pain yes um I I
don't like pain either okay um so I
don't really know why I have this job
but I guess yeah I guess that's Murphy
but so I think now's a good time to
actually start circling in on okay so
what did we do in c-sharp so the first
thing is this expression of intent so I
think we have a couple of options given
that we're adding this to a an existing
language the first sort of knee-jerk
idea is well okay he wants these two
expressions of intent this is definitely
not null and this might be null but it's
protected against unauthorized access
okay the reference types you haven't
seen sharp today on either of those
they're the worst of both worlds right
they're like oh I can shove null in
there and then immediately I can go and
and include and you know dot into it in
the next line literally yeah so there's
some clean stuff there at least it
doesn't it doesn't make me change any of
my code now right so you have that pain
if you do went that way right so but
sort of the this there's definitely a
notion of cleanliness that we've
operated on or under for twenty years
which is add new stuff don't change the
old stuff right okay so we have these
two new concepts neither of which we
have in the language today oh we should
go and add a new kind of nun nullable
reference type and a new kind of
knowledge I reference type to security
and then people can a new code they can
party with those and they can be safe
all over and too bad with what's already
in there that sort of becomes the legacy
reference type that you should maybe try
to avoid right so the idea would be
something like you know this one here we
would call that and that will be none
nullable okay so we annotate it like
that and well actually you know let's
let's move back to where we don't have
the options in there and it's a little
easier to explain this so for a lot of
undo here the undo buffer luckily is
large there we go I think we're back
okay
so we could say that you know this
drink should be none no but the link
should be null and we haven't new
annotation for both and that's just a
new world that's the new world of
c-sharp okay and then okay and then bill
asks me but but I've got code I've gotta
maintain that's exactly what he asks me
and I yes okay so I think it's four
years if you want if you want you if
we'll hopefully you tested it I can't
really help you if you really want to
help what you should do we should
probably have like it Roslin analyzer or
something and we should have a mode and
the compiler that punishes you for all
the legacy references types that you
have in there and makes you put either
bangs or question marks all over your
code so there will be no like uh Nana
tative reference types left in your code
it sounds like pain that sounds like
pain yes and and once you're done your
code will be swearing at you there'll be
banks and question marks everything so
essentially if we try to go that route
immediately people be like well give me
a mode that makes me do the safe thing
break me please essentially punish me
for the code I have now and and make me
do something else well if we're gonna
break you anyway then we've kind of lost
the the benefit of adding these two new
concepts we might as well break you by
taking the existing syntax and
reinterpreting it giving you a mode
where that is reinterpreted as something
else and that's the path we're gonna go
down because now existing code already
means something safe it's either we have
to decide okay do on annotated when I
just say string here do I mean nullable
but now safe nullable or do I mean none
nullable either way I kind of have to
I'm guessing that if I declared a
variable I probably want to put
something in it yeah yeah so it's
probably not no most of the time yes
because I probably wanted something that
right so we could so we could you could
reason either way like some people a lot
of people say to us well obviously types
today can have nulls in them so they're
not able so the new things should be
none nullable right so it should be that
link here is doesn't need annotation but
this one
here needs an annotation saying it's not
null and then the new thing that the way
we break link here is that we start
checking when you dereference things
that are knowable we start checking that
you actually knew that they weren't not
like we started enforcing the
conditional checking so so but yeah I'm
trying to think through my code bases
and I'm going I'm gonna add a lot of
bangs yeah because in most of my designs
I would be trying to say that this
shouldn't be null
yeah because of those I've got if this
isn't null or Elvis operator everywhere
here they're they're all over the place
so I probably try when I can that in my
constructor I'm going to initialize
something to not null and then I'm gonna
use it and it's always safe and then try
and avoid those checks and try to only
put the tracks where somebody might be
trying to set it to no that makes sense
to me so say so the so none all is a
good default right if I want null that's
an extra thing it's like the option of T
that we had before that's the extra
thing that you have to opt into oh I
want to be able to express a null here
and I want to take the extra hurdle of
then doing the checking around it that
should be the opt-in I'm glad you said
that because that's what we actually did
so like I knew the script yeah it's like
you've been here before it's like you
wrote the documentation for this just
yeah okay so this is what we actually
ended up with okay so but but this is
weird like we now have a feature that is
that is a breaking change we've never
had a breaking change in c-sharp before
we have a feature that takes your
existing reference types and makes them
mean something else a feature that
starts punishing you if you put null
into your reference types which is the
only place you could ever put them
before so that's a bit drastic
and of course that has to be under a
switch some kind of an opt-in mechanism
so I'm gonna go and opt-in now which I
can do in my in my project file for the
whole project I'm gonna say enable to
this feature Noble reference types and
save that and go back to my program and
see what happens what happens
oh I start getting warnings so the
feature is doing something it's warning
me about things I didn't add any and it
well actually I did I have an annotation
let's take that away and just see like
just in the vanilla code like if you
went and turned this on when on vanilla
code that you hadn't done anything to
what would happen well you start getting
warnings here and there and the warnings
you'd get should be that you we were
trying to prevent you from putting nulls
into the things that into your reference
types because they're now not nullable
and sure enough here I'm getting a
warning
why isn't in an error by the way why are
we just giving you warnings well I tried
turning it on once mm-hmm and I set
warnings to errors and I turned it off
yeah well you might get a lot of them so
it might be one reason another thing is
that errors actually have semantic
meaning and c-sharp we actually decided
that this feature in order to because we
we are adding this null these inaudible
reference types too you know billions of
lines of source code out there and in
hoping for adoption of it it there has
to be as little impact as possible so
this is a compile time only feature okay
it does not in any way shape or form
change the semantics of the language at
runtime so I think this is this is
something that I think if I understand
exactly what you said I think this makes
me feel a lot better about turning it
out on my existing things so if I turn
it on I don't change any of the source
code anywhere I'm gonna get some
warnings
I've got warnings as errors okay I'm
gonna have to do something maybe turn it
off maybe do something hopefully you've
got a solution there but if I compile it
and I get a neck see its behavior will
be exactly the same as before this
feature can yes so you're only breaking
me at compile time yes if I if I no
matter what I do
my X C is going to be the same so as
long as it's been tested I'm probably
okay as I was before yeah okay that's
exactly the idea so still skeptical but
I'm feeling better
I'm glad okay let's see we have we still
have half an hour left hopefully I can
get you all the way there and you'll
walk out before you do your part of the
talk so so warnings only because air is
actually in c-sharp errors in weird ways
actually have semantic impact it has to
do with overload resolution and lambda
and stuff but actually if you put new
errors into the language you changing
semantics so it's just warnings you can
train on warning 1az errors and that's
not impacting the semantics of the
language so if you really want your
errors you can get them but we're not
making the marriage we're just making
the mornings because you your code still
means the same you should still be able
to compile and run it deal with the
warnings later so that's that's the
reason for that now let's go and chase
down these one let's see what's
happening here so sure enough the thing
that's getting a warning is a null so
that's good it says I cannot convert
there's no literal to an unknowable
reference okay so I'm calling the
constructor down here and sure enough it
says link which means now means the nun
null so if I want to be able to pass
nulls in there which I do I think I do
yeah we need those and someday we need
them in there then I should I should
enter Tait this okay so the warning is
making me improve my signature here okay
now I can't assign it into the into the
property well I can make that one
nullable as well great okay great now we
back to custody there's oh but now I got
another warning why does this one saying
it's saying hey it looks like you maybe
dereferencing a null reference a
possible non reference here and we're
back to getting what was the error
before when we use the option type we're
back to the point in the code where it's
telling us you should probably check
whether this thing is know before you
using it so how can I check for null I
would do question mark that before next
or is that gonna be wrong what will
happen if I do oh no that's not gonna
help us at all is it no you're right
that doesn't help and well now I get it
yeah yeah then I'm passing a null to
this yeah and you know and then I could
make that one nullable these Mel's do
get in the way a lot yeah now I get a
warning here right okay possible do you
ever so either way it's we can't get
away from this we have to do something
conditional it will not let us recurse
forever
right which is you know great so we have
to decide we could we could certainly
make it so it prints link a link a
question mark and maybe we should maybe
we should keep the signature like this
but we can't get away with just you know
conditionally passing null here like the
signature is a link
yeah what we should know you wanted to
do it unlink we can do it either way
yeah so now here comes another thing
like what we what you saw in the in the
option version of it was that they used
pattern matching and there's sort of
like it correct by construction thing
where if the thing was not null I got
the null value in a fresh variable and
and I could just use that one and there
was no way I could do it wrong and we
can attempt the same thing here
using pattern matching so we can say if
link is if it is actually a link and
call it no sorry if linked our next
sorry
is actually a link because that checks
that there that is that only fires when
it's none all right then call it next
and then do those things okay so I want
to do that on the next line here let me
move that down then you know print next
now I'm doing exactly the same thing
pretty much exactly pretty much the same
thing as I did before when we had the
other types a first you know a then I
can print that name okay so I'm only so
I'm conditionally doing the recursive
call but that but but okay so but that's
not how I used to check for now right
that's new like pattern matching is kind
of newfangled and it's correct by
construction that's great but I have all
these you have all this source code you
have all these millions of lines that's
not how you did it
you probably remember to check for L
equal to angle and you had tests and you
you know a lot of your code is actually
not safe and it didn't look like this so
we can't just say oh okay okay we're
using the old null but you have it you
have to have a new way of checking for
now that that's no good either so we
have to be able to recognize your
existing ways of checking for now that's
another way of sort of because we you
want to use this feature to check that
your existing code is null safe and
point out where it isn't it's no good if
it ones every place you're not using
pattern matching I'm sorry I mean that's
just not yeah there's like pattern
matching in 0.3% of all the C sharp code
out there today I'm just making that up
I'm trying I'm writing about it yeah I'm
regular yeah I mean so so that's
fair either so what we so what we want
to do is we want to actually recognize
your your existing old-fashioned null
safe code so let's say that I said if
linked up next let's try this one if
linked up next equals null return that's
a different way of doing it I might have
done that in the past and then if I get
here I will print linked up next and now
you notice I'm not getting a warning if
I didn't do the check I got a warning
but if I do the check I don't get a
warning so magic that's magic or to
choose a different turn it's it's its
flow analysis so so we're actually going
to length to track your variables
through the flow of the code and see
where do we think they can be known so
that's the way that we're trying to
accommodate the fact that you're not you
didn't write code that was correct by
construction in the past in fact you
couldn't but you were still null safe
all right so we will track the value of
variables and whether the compiler
thinks it can be null at a given point
and it knows that if it gets down here
linked up next was can't be null because
if it was then we would have retained
this is completely safe right yeah
anybody see a problem with this yes
another thread could have modified it in
the meantime that's correct
yeah or you know some I'm not calling a
whole lot of things here but you know
some call that I have could secretly
have accessed the object through some
other alias and changed it you know then
you don't even need multiple threads
just because it's null up here doesn't
necessarily mean that it's null down
here and so as sort of a courtesy to
existing code we we allow this to go
through anyway which shows an important
point that there's a trade-off between
the amount of pain we want
to inflict on you and the accuracy that
we can do this with if we wanted to be
more accurate we would only track local
variables and only if no lambda had
captured them and you know somebody else
could execute and something that mutates
them and so that would be the safest
thing to do but then more of your
there's lots of existing code like this
right and more of your existing code
would then generate warnings even though
it when you wrote it that it was safe
enough like you so but but okay we are
missing the opportunity to tell you
about maybe a risking there's gonna be
evil okay you gotta be Machiavelli I'm
gonna be evil okay tell me what you're
doing I'm just going to show how you can
be evil here okay that's what next year
okay Oh see you you're gonna use an evil
null check you're not evil enough I'm
afraid it's not evil enough we're still
catching it because it doesn't know that
you are it doesn't know that you're
pretending to do a null check yes you
could so the implementation of next it
so how's that did you design oh I did an
Evo mall track there so I just added an
exclamation point oh we have talked
about exclamation okay we'll do that
thing so there are definitely ways that
you can trick it right and even if
you're not Machiavelli but you just
Murphy
mm-hmm there will be places where this
will not catch your no reference
exceptions this is not going to
guarantee that null reference exceptions
go away it's just going to take care of
the vast majority of them but we want to
hit that
probably not 80/20 but more like in
ninety ten trade-off where we get almost
all of them but we really don't want to
cost you too much pain on your existing
code and so that's essentially the
design rationale here we're not in a
black and white situation we're we're
trying to find the right place in the
gray zone between reasonable convenience
and upgrading existing code versus
reasonable safety around nulls so that
feels a little dirty but the extremes
we've tried one extreme of it which is
not to check anything it's extremely
convenient you never get new errors new
compile time errors an existing code and
we've seen sort of the functional other
extreme of it and it's unwieldy and in
and practically impossible in an
object-oriented language so we have to
put ourselves somewhere in the middle
and that somewhere is different because
c-sharp is an existing language with
existing code then it might be in a new
language where you can take it a little
further probably to the
correct side because you can make
everybody use pattern matching always in
a new language for instance or other
correct by construed by construction and
features now you you kind of broke us
into a little extra feature that we have
this they're these these places where
you know better okay like here let's say
it wasn't evil null check but it was
just null check okay so I'm just gonna
rename it for now I'm not actually gonna
make it not evil but let's say I know
that after this you know I check for
null but the compiler doesn't know well
there are several things that that could
happen here actually we use several
utility methods have special null
semantics this string that is null or
empty and stuff like that and and we're
coming up with this little attribute
language that we're gonna let you
attribute some methods as having special
null behavior and the compiler is gonna
recognize those that gets into the
gnarly z' but that even then there's
going to be situations where you know
better than the compiler and that's what
we have until recently called the damage
operator which is like I know what I'm
doing shut up and we can't call it that
for various reasons so we're gonna
probably call it the the suppression
operator or something like that which is
a postfix bang so it kind of looks like
damnit you know asserting this is
alright
don't give me warnings on this
particular conversion and and it makes
the morning go away but now you use it's
like a cast you sort of took
responsibility that you know if an
exception occurs here you kind of ask
for it if you weren't right that you
knew what you were doing it takes you
back into the old world temporarily so
John asks how bad do I feel when used in
production code and I I would be very
wary of it generally if you need to use
it in order to interact with another API
then something's probably wrong if if
you have an implementation detail where
say there's an invariant that when this
field this boolean is false and that
thing is net
all right um we have lots of those cases
waiting our little implementation types
in in the in the core libraries for
instance then you know that's this
invariant you put it in a comment you
say there is this invariant and
essentially every bang in your code
should be accompanied by a comment
saying why you think it's okay to have
it there that would be my guidance and
make sure that it's very locally scoped
there's a few other places where I've
seen it as I've been starting to work
through Docs where we're going to talk
about migrating code bases if you think
of your average dto object pulling data
out of a database and stuffing fields in
most of those have public getters and
setters because serialization is really
hard on an immutable object so those
properties are going to be initialized
to null and then the but before you ever
actually see it because we're going to
deserialize something into it then they
become not null those properties the
compilers going to complain about
because hey you can construct this by
default that's going to all be null
these are all bad and then there's some
idioms I'll show in the in the next hour
to say here's how I can say I know this
doesn't happen because of the semantics
of the object and like matt says though
you if I'm just hitting bang I probably
feel really bad but if it's like okay I
know how this thing was designed it was
designed not to be null in some other
way that flow analysis won't help then I
can turn it on and I can say why I did
turn it on yeah so don't be Tony Hoare
at 3:00 a.m. be like oh nobody's gonna
care yeah so but but you that's a good
segue to talk about how does this
feature work in in connection with
initialization we talked about
initialization it can be hard to you
know it can be hard to manage but we try
so here's the here's a class where it's
a person class it has first name middle
name and last name and it has a
convenience constructor that only takes
the first and last name and assigns
those in and I'm getting a warning on it
by the feature here which is saying that
there's an unknowable property that I'm
not initializing so it so essentially
the compiler tries to make you
initialize all the non null things in
the constructor
and that's how you're gonna discover
many of the places that this type you
know that your type should should
actually put question marks in that they
should actually advertise nail ability
so sure enough if I you know I can try
to circumvent this in various ways I can
say okay I'm gonna it says it's not
initialized while I'm gonna initialize
it let me show you and you know I've
initialized it there you go and the
warning goes away but I get another one
saying hey you can't assign null to that
none no thing and of course this is
where you know if it's if it's 3 a.m. I
would just do this and then go back walk
away and and sometimes if you're in a
situation where you really know that
it's going to be initialized through
other means or it's okay for some reason
yeah you can you can put the bang there
or you can you can put an initializer
alright with null bang and that's how
you opt out saying okay I know better
you know that you have this factory
method that's actually calling the
constructor and filling in the remaining
fields whatever it is but what we really
should do in this case is just just be
honest and say okay middle names in this
model here probably in reality all names
can probably be no like nobody it's not
everyone who has a first name or a last
name or a middle name I do for
simplicity let's just say the middle
name here I mean just just be honest it
can sometimes be now now now
everything's happy here but of course if
I go and if I go and use it if I go and
write the print method for for four
persons you know static Corinne this is
all print method set is only tested on
print methods and person person what
else is there right um and who you know
with debugging these days even the
person yes print that's pretty much what
we write so if so an hour if I say come
to all the right line let's just say
right line you know let's do a an
interpolator string and we say that's
called this person is too long let's see
P dot
P dot first name we can say P dat middle
name here but if I could eat men middle
name and so on right but and I'm allowed
to do that I can print null but let's
say that I want to abbreviate the middle
name so I'm gonna do this here okay I'm
just gonna print the first letter of the
middle name you know now I actually get
a warning saying hey you're do
referencing something that might be no
and so it's helping you here which so so
I really should like do a conditional
here and print print it differently or
here I could use the question mark I
could so I could use things the question
right now P dot middle name question
mark zero after middle name right there
I could then I would get null if right
but it's ok to print nulls we just said
that yeah yeah yeah that's right I could
do that yeah let's say so but it but it
helps me realize the problem is there
and so actually one thing that you
shouldn't let this feature do to you and
and I think many people have the just
because none all is the default now many
people sort of have the there we go
there we go many people sort of have the
okay we should actually be avoiding
nulls now to be null safe we should
avoid null and either you can easily go
too far on the null avoidance they avoid
avoiding null is sort of what I would
say and if null is warranted better to
use null than to try to substitute some
other default value so let's say that
okay I wanted to in I wanted to deal
with this problem by by assigning the
empty string to middle name
okay and that's not null so everything's
fine i circumvented the problem but now
you know this is still going to crash at
runtime because it doesn't have a first
element or cirith element because it's
empty right so I just in fact I should
probably have a check in my constructor
that you don't put an olive oyl string
would
strings in any of the name fields so you
just chased it out of the area that we
just learned how to reason about a
compile time and give you warnings about
it's better to use the actual null and
the actual not about type and then get
the warnings when you're not doing it
right
don't shy away from using nulls and use
them whenever they make sense so I think
that was an important point to get yeah
there's a few more places so we talked
about this is there holes in this one of
the big holes that I do feel bad about
is that is a race so there's a lot of
arrays in the world probably like
scientifically around 50% of them are a
race of reference types I'm just making
up okay so all over the world there'll
be people saying var array equals new
string 10 okay that nowhere in the world
is anyone yet saying you string question
mark 10 because they can't it's only
teach our age it's not out yet
John skeet will have some code that does
it but that's only because he's using
the preview okay
so this is what's going to be there all
over the place millions and millions of
millions of lines of creating a race
that will now be interpreted as a race
of an unknowable reference type and it's
full of nulls right there's ten nulls in
there should we give it warning on that
yeah we probably should for correctness
sake but we'd be like and all that code
which is probably like the next thing it
does is probably to initialize the array
with proper proper and good not null
values right and in all the cases where
it with you don't mean for null to be in
there like when you mean for null to be
in there of course yes you should go and
put the question why again but when you
don't mean for null to be in there
that's just what you were able to say
and then you the next three lines will
be initializing it in a for loop or
whatever what what can you do about a
warning that says
you couldn't if you shouldn't create
this array of null I mean it three lines
down it's gonna be fine you knew what
you were doing
how could you silence that warning how
could you possibly make it shut up makes
tracks what's that these drug trucks all
the time
yeah circum so then the struct has what
inside and no yeah so yeah I mean so it
this is one of those difficult ones so
we've we've opted to not give you a
warning on that we've we talked about
there so there are these places where we
don't go and we we don't favor
correctness we talked about having sort
of a ludicrous mode where you know you
tell the compiler not only should you
turn on in all ability in inaudible
reference types but you should like go
all the way correct by construction
don't let me build anything that has and
like these unwanted nulls inside I go
all the way as far as we can and
probably there'll be tiny little errors
or a whole set that just you know
constructors calling virtual methods
doing something in a in a drive class we
don't know about I get there'll be
places where we can't go that we can't
figure out it's just not doable at
compile time but you know anything other
than that
or maybe we've worn on constructors
calling virtual methods of any kind you
know make the ludicrous mode that will
not let any of this seep through and
maybe some people want that in
particular for new code or if they they
have security crew who code so we're
talking about in if we don't make the
ludicrous mode they'll be you know
somebody like John or whoever will write
the analyzer that does it like that adds
the extra warnings and so I think there
will be that mode as well out there and
the fact that you have the ability to to
express the intent to put the question
marks or not that means that we can now
have these analyzers and we can have
different levels that can exist out
there different levels of rigor around
how we how we then enforce it okay yeah
there's a few that you went pretty quick
here since this this is your last demo
part right I think so because that that
bit of empty string and such is one that
I think we're going to I'm already
seeing questions and and discussions
about this because you know we already
had the empty string forever which was
how you represent there isn't a string
here
but it's almost like this extends to
other reference types more importantly
and that right now the only way you
represent there isn't anything here is
null so string is kind of special
because we're maybe using it just to
print so it might be right just to make
it the empty string but this whole
redefining to have a different meaning
for null I think that's going to be an
interesting way for people to really
have to question what is the right way
to fix code that uses that that type at
least yeah I mean the empty string isn't
isn't a very good solution here no it's
not just that we can't index into it hey
if we if we're actually like if we if we
output the last name here as well and
you know full middle name even if it's
null and nothing comes out you're gonna
have two spaces between the first name
and the last name it's just like you do
it's just not good no you want a special
case whether it's there or not and
something one way or another but yeah I
mean we're solving the null problem but
all of the lengths related problems say
I mean null reference exceptions are
probably by far like by orders of
magnitude the most common exception but
the next one down is probably index out
of range exception
all right that's or or similar like
you're you're indexing into a string or
an array or something and you and you
got it wrong right and so there's that
next level down of you know is there
some static analysis that could help you
always stay within range well that's a
much harder problem still that's like
hard and it's not I I don't personally
believe you could probably ever add that
to an existing language you need a
language that has safer constructs to
begin with and then dynamically
allocated arrays and so on it will
probably be restrictive and very
annoying ways no but I like this I think
I'm starting to see some things where as
we start to modify some code in the next
session I'm starting to see the plan my
idea here is if I'm looking something is
not just to get rid of warnings anyway I
can
it's to look at those warnings and ask
myself what's that expressing about what
my design was yes how my design isn't
really expressed in my code and then
modify my code to go okay now the
compiler agrees with me about what my
design
and if I fix it that way I probably have
less to do because I had a design intent
and if I fix it by getting it that way
then the compiler is helping me make
sure that the code I wrote expresses the
design intent I had right
I like this good good just in time you
have a we have a minute left so I want
you over now I just have to be careful
and last minute not to say something
that will turn you around again yeah so
I think we've pretty much covered
everything here in terms of the language
to sign there are little details that
may become bigger details when we get
into bills talk I opted the whole
project in to like the heart of the new
heart a cement I said please break all
my code in this project by changing some
setting on the product at the project
level and you might wonder as you
migrate code is that the right
granularity to opt into this new world
and that's something that you will there
are ways of doing it in a more granular
fashion that I didn't show and that's
something I think we will see in Bill's
part in the next next generation so
there we will look at both like how sure
think about it when I write new code and
how should I and by example
Bill's going to upgrade some code
onstage and take us through the steps of
becoming null safe with your existing
code so that's pretty much it go have a
break and if you want to hear the second
part of act 2 where Bill's the hero then
please come back in 20 minutes it's
healing thank you
[Applause]